.
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
FIRST, BIDEN'S PLAN TO DESTROY
AMERICA.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
NOW IF YOU WANTED TO DEVISE A
PLAN FOR AMERICA'S FOREIGN
POLICY THAT WORKED TOTALLY CROSS
PURPOSES, YOU'D BE HARD-PRESSED
TO MATCH WHAT BIDEN AND HIS TEAM
ARE DOING RIGHT NOW.
LET'S GO THROUGH THE STEPS.
NUMBER 1, DESTROY AMERICA'S
ENERGY DEPENDENCE.
OUR ENERGY SUPPLIES FROM
LOUISIANA TO PENNSYLVANIA TO
CALIFORNIA WOULD POWER US FOR
ABOUT 400 YEARS OR SO.
BUT THE GREENIACS WANT IT SHUT
DOWN.
AS A RESULT, AMERICANS ARE
SUFFERING.
HIGH PRICES FOR EVERYTHING AND
STILL CLIMBING.
BIDEN'S ANECDOTES ABOUT HIS
CHILDHOOD DON'T HELP.
>> WE'RE GOING THROUGH AN
INCREDIBLE TRANSITION THAT IS
TAKING PLACE.
IT'S BAD.
THE PRICE OF GAS AT THE PUMP IS
SOMETHING THAT I TOLD YOU, YOU
HEARD ME SAY BEFORE, IT WOULD BE
A MATTER OF GREAT DISCUSSION
WHEN I WAS A KID GROWING UP.
>> Laura: STILL WITH THAT TIRED
OLD LINE.
THE TRANSITION -- COME ON.
I LOVE THE MEANINGLESS EUPHEMISM
BY BIDEN.
THIS ANTI-FOSSIL FUEL OBSESSION
IS MAKING US WEAKER.
WE'VE GONE FROM SELF-SUFFICIENT
TO DEPENDENT.
WE'RE BEGGARS FOR ENERGY FROM
DESPITS FROM AROUND THE WORLD.
STEP NUMBER 2 IS TO MAKE CHINA
RICH AND POWERFUL.
>> COMPETITION THAT IS HEALTHY
IS GOOD.
THAT'S WHY I'VE HELD THE VIEW
FOR SO MANY YEARS AND CONTINUE
TO HOLD THE VIEW THAT A RISING
CHINA IS A POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT.
>> Laura: SO OF COURSE, 11 YEARS
LATER, BIDEN WILL REWARD CHINA
FOR ALL OF THAT GOOD BEHAVIOR
DURING COVID BY LIFTING TRUMP'S
TARIFFS ON MADE IN CHINA GOODS
THAT ENTER THE UNITED STATES.
YEAH, I WISH I WERE JOKING.
ARE YOU CONSIDERING TAKING DOWN
SOME OF THOSE TARIFFS?
>> I'M TALKING WITH THE
SECRETARY WHEN WE GET HOME.
I AM CONSIDERING IT.
WE DID NOT IMPOSE ANY OF THOSE
TARIFFS.
THEY'RE UNDER CONSIDERATION.
>> Laura: HE WOULD LIKE TO LIFT
THE TARIFFS.
THE ONLY REASON HE'S NOT DONE IT
YET, HE'S AFRAID OF THE VOTERS.
THE GOP LEADERSHIP ALSO WANT
THEM LIFTED LIKE YESTERDAY.
AND OUR ENRICHMENT OF THE C.C.P.
EXTENDS TO AMERICA'S COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES THAT GLADLY
MATRICULATE MORE THAN 300,000
STUDENTS EVERY YEAR.
WHEN BIDEN WAS PRESIDENT, THE
NUMBER WAS HALF THAT BUT HE WAS
GIDDY.
>> LAST YEAR 130,000 CHINESE
STUDENTS WERE STUDYING IN THE
EASY.
THEY'RE REALLY GOOD.
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO KEEP SOME
OF THEM.
I'M JOKING.
BUT THEY ARE.
>> Laura: CREEPY.
HIGH PROFILE FEDERAL
INVESTIGATIONS OF CHINESE SPIES
ON ACADEMIA SHOULD HAVE PUSHED
US TO STOP THE PRACTICE LONG
AGO.
WE DIDN'T.
>> THE CHAIRMAN OF HARVARD
UNIVERSITY'S CHEMISTRY
DEPARTMENT ARRESTED BY FBI
AGENTS CHARGED WITH LYING ABOUT
MORE THAN A MILLION DOLLARS IN
PAYMENTS FROM THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
A BOSTON UNIVERSITY RESEARCHER
ACCUSED OF BEING A SECRET
OPERATIVE OF THE CHINESE
MILITARY.
ANOTHER HARVARD RESEARCHER
CAUGHT AT THE AIRPORT ALLEGEDLY
TRYING TO SMUGGLE BIOLOGICAL
MATERIALS TO CHINA.
>> Laura: WHAT COULD GO WRONG?
BIOLOGICAL MATERIALS GOING TO
CHINA?
DURING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
THE FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT GOT
VERY SERIOUS ABOUT STOPPING
CHINESE ESPIONAGE ON THESE
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
UNDER BIDEN, CHINA, OF COURSE,
IS GETTING A FREE PASS.
NOW AT THE SAME TIME, BIDEN AND
MANY GOP OLD GUARD-TYPES WANT US
TO GET DEEPER IN TO THE EASTERN
EUROPEAN QUAGMIRE BY WHAT WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY END UP BEING
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF WEAPONS
TO UKRAINE THAT IS STEP THROUGH.
>> THE COST OF THIS FIGHT IS NOT
CHEAP.
CAVING TO AGGRESSION IS GOING TO
BE MORE COSTLY IF WE ALLOW IT TO
HAPPEN.
>> MY COLLEAGUE, SENATOR PAUL,
HAS BEEN AN ISOLATION IT'S.
HE'S PROUD OF IT AND BELIEVES
THAT'S WHERE AMERICA OUGHT TO
BE.
THAT IS A TINY PERCENTAGE OF THE
SENATE REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A STRAND OF
ISOLATIONISM IN OUR PARTY BUT
IT'S NOT ANYWHERE NEAR THE
DOMINANT VIEW.
>> Laura: OH REALLY?
I THINK McCONNELL AND RAND PAUL
SHOULD TOUR THE COUNTRY AND
DEBATE THAT $40 BILLION PRICE
TAG FOR UKRAINE IN TOWN HALLS IN
FRONT OF ALL OF THESE PEOPLE AND
SEE WHO ENDS UP WINNING THE
AUDIENCE VOTE.
ANYBODY TAKE A WAGER ON THAT?
I WILL.
AND IRRESPONSIBLE IS A WORD THAT
I'D USE TO DESCRIBE THEIR PROXY
WAR WITH RUSSIA.
>> THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WE CAN DO TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST THE POTENTIAL CHINESE
AGGRESSION IS TO HELP THE
UKRAINIANS DEFEAT THE RUSSIANS
IN THIS CURRENT CONFLICT.
>> Laura: EXCUSE ME?
THE GLOBALISTS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR TURNING CHINA INTO A GLOBAL
SUPER POWER.
THE SINGLE GREATEST THREAT TO
FREEDOM WORLDWIDE.
SO EVERY STINGER MISSILE WE GIVE
TO UKRAINE IS ONE THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE USES TO DEFEND
TAIWAN.
THEY WANT U.S. TROOPS THERE AS
WELL.
THEY DO.
WE HAVE ALREADY UPPED OUR
NUMBERS IN EASTERN EUROPE AND
MILLIE IS ITCHING FOR MORE.
>> MY ADVICE WOULD BE TO CREATE
PERMANENT BASES BUT NOT
PERMANEN
PERMANENT PERSONNEL.
A LOT OF OUR ALLIES ESTABLISH
PERMANENT BASES.
THEY'LL BUILD THEM AND PAY FOR
THEM.
>> Laura: THEY'LL PAY FOR THEM?
ANOTHER WAGER I'LL TAKE.
STEP 4.
BIDEN WILL SHIP MORE U.S. JOBS
OVERSEAS, ESPECIALLY TO ASIA.
NOW WHEN U.S. MANUFACTURERS CAN
MOVE OPERATIONS TO ASIA, THIS
MEANS AMERICA IS MORE DEPENDENT
ON ASIAN SUPPLY CHAINS.
BUT BIDEN, WHO HAS BEEN WRONG ON
EVERY TRADE DEAL HE'S VOTED ON
SAYS DON'T WORRY.
BE HAPPY.
>> THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING
TODAY.
FOR THE LAUNCH OF THE
INDOPACIFIC FRAME WORK FOR
PROSPERITY.
NATIONS REPRESENTED HERE TODAY
ARE SIGNING UP TO WORK TOWARD AN
ECONOMIC VISION THAT WILL
DELIVER FOR ALL PEOPLE.
WHERE ECONOMIC GROWTH IS
SUSSTAINABLE AND INCLUSIVE.
>> Laura: INCLUSIVE GROWTH.
THEY PROBABLY THINK THAT BY
BRIBING THESE COUNTRIES WITH
JOBS AND MONEY, THESE SAME
COUNTIES WILL RALLY TO OUR SIDE
WHEN CHINA MAKES THEIR MOVE.
IT'S MORE NAIVE THINKING.
EVERY COUNTRY FROM AUSTRALIA TO
SINGAPORE WILL GO WITH THE
WINNER IN THIS ECONOMIC BATTLE.
IF WE END UP WEAKER, THEY'RE
GOING TO ALIGN THEMSELVES WITH
CHINA.
WELCOME TO REALITY, KIDS.
WHEN WE DON'T MAKE IMPORTANT
STUFF HERE AS WE LEARNED DURING
THE PANDEMIC, WE LOSE CONTROL
AND THEN WE OPEN OURSELVES UP
FOR A TON OF HURT.
SO WE HAVE SHORTAGES IN
MEDICINES AND RAW MATERIALS TO
NAME A FEW.
AND THEN STEP FIVE.
AFTER HE BANKRUPTS US, HELPS
CHINA AND DEPLETES OUR MUNITIONS
AND MANPOWER, BIDEN BELIEVES WE
SHOULD GO TO WAR OVER TAIWAN.
>> ARE YOU WILLING TO GO TO WAR
TO DEFEND TAIWAN?
>> YES.
>> YOU ARE?
>> THAT'S A COMMITMENT WE MADE.
>> Laura: HOW DO OUR GENIUSES
PLAN TO FIGHT A COUNTRY AFTER
STEPS 1-4 WHO HAS A BIGGER
ECONOMY A BIGGER ARMY, AIR
FORCE, ECONOMY AND A BIGGER NAVY
THAN WE'LL HAVE?
HOW DO THEY PLAN TO FIGHT A
COUNTRY'S WHOSE LEADERS WERE
TRAINED IN OUR UNIVERSITIES AND
HAS THE BEST LOBBIESTS IN
WASHINGTON?
THEY COULDN'T OUTSMART THE
TALIBAN.
HAVE THEY THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT
WOULD BECOME AMERICA IF WE LOST
A WAR WITH CHINA?
WE SHOULD BE VERY CLEAR HERE.
WE WILL NOT SUPPORT ANY MORE OF
THE ESTABLISHMENT'S WARS OR
WASTE ANY MORE MONEY ON
INCREASES IN OUR PENTAGON BUBBLE
UNLESS WE DECOUPLE FROM THE CCP.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE POLICY, TAKE
NEW PRAGMATIC STEPS OR GIVE UP
OR TAIWAN WHICH WOULD BE A
COMPLETE CAPITULATION.
THINK ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE UNDERSTOOD THAT KEEPING THE
PEACE REQUIRED KEEPING OUR
STRENGTH.
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH IS WHAT
REAGAN SAID.
NOW WE'RE BACK IN THIS GLOBALIST
DREAM WORLD.
PRESIDENT XI ISN'T.
HE KNOWS HOW POWER HE HAS AND
HOW MUCH POWER HE HAS.
IF AND WHEN HE THINKS THE
BALANCE OF POWER HAS SHIFTED IN
CHINA'S FAVOR, HE'S GOING TO
MOVE ON TAIWAN.
THE SAD FACT IS IF THEY HAVE THE
MONEY, THE RESOURCES AND THE
MINDS TRAINED HERE, THEY COULD
WIN.
SO IT'S TIME TO TELL THE
ESTABLISHMENT THAT IT'S TIME TO
CHOOSE.
IF YOU WANT TO HELP FINLAND AND
SWEDEN AND NATO BECAUSE OF
PUTIN'S AGGRESSION, THAT'S FINE.
BUT LET'S STOP PRETENDING
THROUGH A PIVOT TO ASIA THAT
MATTERS.
YOU CANNOT DO BOTH.
THEIR PLAN IS TO STRENGTHEN OUR
ENEMIES, WEAKEN US, THEN GO
FIGHT MORE WARS.
TRUMP'S PLAN WAS TO WEAKEN OUR
ENEMIES, STRENGTHEN OURSELVES
AND AVOID NEW WARS.
MAKE SENSE, RIGHT?
COMMON SENSE.
OUR NATION IS HURTING.
YOU CAN FEEL IT, RIGHT?
OUR PEOPLE ARE PESSIMISTIC.
IT'S HORRIBLE TO SEE THAT.
THEY'RE BEGINNING TO THINK OUR
POLITICAL LEADERS DON'T KNOW HOW
TO TURN THINGS AROUND EVEN IF
THEY WANTED TO.
EVERY WEEK WHEN THEY LOOK AT
THEIR FAMILY BUDGETS, AMERICANS
HAVE TO MAKE HARD CHOICES.
CALL ME CRAZY, B